[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء شيعت في
القاهره جنازات ثمانيه من افراد الشرطه
المصريه بينهم ضابط برتبه نقيب قتلوا في
هجوم تبناه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
على حافله صغيره كانت تقلهم في منطقه
حلوان جنوبي القاهره وقالت وزاره الداخليه
المصريه ان اربعه مسلحين ترجلوا من سياره
اعترضت قوه من المباحث يرتدي افرادها زيا
مدنيا واطلقوا عليها الرصاصه بكثافه ثم
لاذوا بالفرار نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في محورين الى اي مدن تمثل العمليه خرقا
امنيا وتطورا نوعيا في نشاط تنظيم الدوله
بعد توسيعه رقعه عملياته خارج
سيناء وهل يعتبر هذا تتويجا لفشل سياسي
وامني رغم اعلان القاهره انها لن تتهاون
في الدفاع عن امن البلاد
واستقرارها اذا ليست المره الاولى في
القاهره ولا في حلوان التي تقع على
اطرافها الجنوبيه فقد نقل تنظيم الدوله
كثيرا من عملياته من شمال سيناء الى دائره
اوسع بحجم خريطه البلاد ضاربا السياحه
والسياسه والامن وفق مقاربه نظام الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي كما نقل في الوقت ذاته
اسلوب عملياته من التفجيرات والكمائن
الكبرى الى نهج اقل اثاره للانتباه من
احدث فصوله قتل ثمانيه من رجال الامن في
خاصره القاهره الجنوبيه
حلوان تقرير فاطمه
تريكي هجوم مباغت مدروس لهدف مرصو وعلى
تخوم العاصمه في جوف الليل وخلال مرور
دوريه لرجال شرطه مباحث حلوان كانوا
بملابس مدنيه ويركبون حافله صغيره للركاب
وهو المعتاد منهم عندما يذهبون لدهم او
اعتقال اوقفهم اربعه مسلحين بحسب بيان
وزاره الداخليه الم ريه وامطر بالرصاص من
بنادق اليه ثم صوروه قبل ان يلوذ الفاعلون
الملثمون بالفرار دون ان يطلقوا رصاصه
واحده قتل افراد الشرطه وهم ثمانيه بينهم
ضابط برتبه نقيب قالت وزاره الداخليه انهم
كانوا يتفقدون الامن وتعهدت بالرد على
الارهاب باراده وعنف تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه فرع سيناء اصدر بيانا تبنى فيه
الهجوم وقال انه فار للنساء المعتقلات
والانتهاكات التي تقع بحقهن في سجون مصر
لكن قراءه في شكل واسلوب وتوقيت ومكان ما
جرى يحيل حتما الى تطور كبير وخطير في
المواجهه القائمه بين النظام المصري
والتنظيم فهجم حلوان يماثل ما يتعرض له
الجيش في سيناء من استهداف مباشر لعسكريين
بينما كانت معظم الهجمات السابقه تتم
بتفجيرات
متفرقه مثل ما وقع مطلع هذا العام في
القاهره وادى الى قتل سبعه رجال شرطه
وقبله تفجير مبنى امن الدوله الصيف الماضي
في شبره لقد تمدد التنظيم في هجوم الاحد
بعيدا عن معاقله في سيناء حيث تدور حرب
صغيره بينه وبين القوات المسلحه تتخللها
وقائع صادمه عن انتهاكات لحقوق المدنيين
تغذي براي كثر نشوء حاضنه شعبيه له في حين
يقول انصار النظام المص
انما يجري حلقه من حلقات الارهاب المتصاعد
في المنطقه والعالم ويرى فيه بعضهم مبررا
لقبضه الامنيه التي يحكم السيسي بواسطتها
وصولا الى توظيف ذلك في معاركه السياسيه
والاعلاميه مع خصومه لكن رايا اخر يقول
بان ما جراه ليس الا حلقه من حلقات
الاخفاق الامني والسياسي لرئيس رسخ حكما
بوليسيا تحت شعار مكافحه الارهاب لكنه جاء
والتنظيم في سيناء وهاهو في عامه الثالث
يجول في
القاهره ومناقشه موضوع حلقتنا معنا في
الاستوديو حاتم عزام عضو مجلس الشعب
المصري السابق ومن القاهره عبر سكايب
محمود ابراهيم نائب مدير مركز الاتحاديه
للدراسات ومن القاهره ايضا سيكون معنا عبر
الهاتف رفيق حبيب مساعد وزير الداخليه
المصري الاسبق وابدا مع السيد محمود
ابراهيم من القاهره سيد محمود اي دلالات
تفرزها هذه العمليه التي تبناها تنظيم
الدوله ان لجهه تفاصيلها او المنطقه التي
حدثت بها وي حلوان جنوب
القاهره الدلاله الاساسيه انه الضربات
الامنيه التي تمت خلال الشهر الماضي في
سيناء حجمت التنظيم بشكل كبير فاراد ان
يرد بشكل
اعلامي هذه عمليه انا اصنفها انها رغم
انها تغير نوعيا الى انها نوعيا بسيطه ا
فهو اختار مجموعه من رجال الشرطه غير
مؤهلين للتعامل مع هذا النوع من الارهاب
هم يتعاملون مع حركه الحوادث العاديه في
الشارع سرقه سرقه بالاكراه بعض التفقد
الامنيه العاديه في الشارع المصري اختار
مجموعه من ضابط ومجموعه من امناء الشرطه
هم ليسوا مدربين بشكل كافي على مكافحه
الارهاب وليسوا في وضع استعداد او في
مواجهه مع ارهاب هذه المساله هذه الضربه
اراد انا ارى فيها محاوله
لبناء بشكل اعلامي انهم نجحوا في اختراق
القاهره في الحقيقه الاختراقات السابقه
كانت اصعب القنابل التي وصلت والتي اشار
اليها التقرير يبدو انها لم تعد سهله
الوصول الى قلب القاهره او اطرافها ف
فتوضا عن ذلك نوع من هذه العمليات تتسم
بالغدر ولكن لها تاثير كبير لكن هناك عفوا
عفوا سيد اف سي سيدي ابراهيم هناك هناك من
يقول في المقابل
ب ان المساله لا تعني تحجي بقدر ما تعني
توسعا بالنسبه لتنظيم الدوله ثم انما قام
به بهذه الاريحيه التي اعتبرتها انت مساله
غير نوعيه لكن البعض يرى بانه يتصرف
ويتحرك في القاهره بشكل مريح جدا بدليل
انه يحمل سلاحا في الشوارع ثم ينزل
اي يعني عناصر شرطه ويقتلهم ويلوذون
بالفرار من دون ان يتعقبه
احد نحن نتحدث عن اسلحه هي مدافع رشاشه
وفقا لكل الشهود مدفع نسبيا يعني رشاش من
النوع اللي هو السريع الطلقات هذه النوعيه
استطيع ان اقول انها رغم انها غير منتشره
بشكل واسع الا انها اسهل في في التهريب
وفي
التنقل وليس معنى الارهاب قائم على الغدر
ليس المعنى قيامه بالغدر مره انه يستطيع
او او انه ينال من او يتجول بحريه او كل
هذه الامور نحن نتحدث عن تنظيم كان يستطيع
ان يزرع قنبله في وقت ما الان هو لا
يستطيع ذلك فيعوض عن ذلك بنوعيه على اطراف
القاهره الحلوان ل وفقا لمن يعرف هي جنوب
القاهره هي اقرب الى الصعيد والى جبال
الصعيد والى هذه المناطق التي يستطيع
الهروب فيها هو لا يستطيع ان يدخل الى وسط
القاهره حتى الان مساله سيجيب عنها
العمليات اللاحقه هل يستطيع ان يستمر في
ضربات موجعه للامن على فترات قريبه ام هذه
هي كما يقولون المصريين حلاوه روح يعني ام
اي سيد
عزام كما
سمعت العمليه تعني بان التنظيم لم يعد
قادرا على التفخيخ وعلى التفجير فبدا يلجا
الى هذه العمليات الاقل نوعيه مما كان
يقوم به في السابق ما رايك اولا دعني
اتوجه بالعزاء لاهالي الضحايا الدم المصري
كله حرام ا كل الذين يسقطون من مصريين
مدنيين او شرطيين هو دم مصري دم حرام قتله
خارج نطاق القانون مجرب ومؤثر بكل يعني
القانون والاعراف و وكل المواثيق ا نحن
نرى انه الحقيقه هناك العديد من الدلالات
هذه الحديث انا احدثك وانا كنت انا ابن
هذه المنطقه ابن حلوان نشات فيها في منطقه
المعادي المجاوره وعشت فيها معظم ايام
حياتي فاعلها شبرا
شبرا نحن هناك روايتان روايه تبنتها تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه واعل على لسان وعلى
صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي كما ان هناك
روايه اخرى لابد ان ننظر اليها ايضا وان
نقيم الاثنين على مدار الوقت القليل
القادم وهي روايه تقول ان هناك عمليه ثار
من عرب ابو ساعد
في مدينه الصف 15 كيلو بعدا عن حلوان وهي
هناك هناك العديد من تجار هناك العديد من
المخدرات والاسلحه في هذه المنطقه دي نمره
واحد ا ما كان من فعل هذا هو تنظيم الدوله
او عمليه ثاريه من عرب ابو ساعد انا اتمنى
الا يكون تنظيم الدوله لانه هذا يعني
بوضوح اختراق واضح لقلب القاهره حلوان وحي
حلوان في جنوب القاهره الحادث كان على بعد
بسيط جدا من قسم الشرطه
حلوان كانوا الضباط يرتدون ذيا مدنيا
وبالتالي ده معناه لو كانت هذه هي الدوله
الاسلاميه فده يثبت انه سياسات جنرال
الانقلاب العسكري عبد الفتاح السيسي التي
اعلن عنها منذ ثلاث سنوات حينما كان
الارهاب محتملا بين هلالين كما اعلن هو
حتى الان فشلت بل انها تمددت حتى وصلت
داخل القاهره واصبحنا نرى ما نرى النقطه
الاخرى الحقيقه ودي في غايه الاهميه ودعني
نتكلم فيها ولازم
نطرحها الامن المصري الذي كان يعني مشحونا
ومهيئين فرا لمحاصرته الصحفيين ومحاصر كل
وسائل الاحتجاج السلمي من المتظاهرين
السلميين الذين ينادون بعدم التفريط في
الاراضي المصريه يوم 25 ابريل واذاقهم سوء
العذاب و قروم نعم تقهقر ولم نرى له يعني
اي اثر حينما كانت تهاجم قوات الامن امام
اقسام الشرطه وهذا هو الحادث اذا انت امام
سلطه تجند كل الجيش والشرطه ومؤسسات
البوليسيه بتاعتها لقمع المدنيين السلميين
المطالبين بحقوقهم في ارضهم المصريه هناك
كانت تظاهرات 25 ابريل ا المناديه بعدم
التفريط في الاراضي المصريه وفي جزيرتي
تيران وصنافير ثم كانت وقفه نقابه
الصحفيين التي احتشدت قوات الشرطه كلها لت
وقها ولمنع الصحفيين من دخول واقتحام
النقابه بل وحشد البلطجيه حوالين النقابه
ثم الان اين هذه القوات هذه النقطه
بالتحديد اريد ان اسال بها السيد رفيق
حبيب مساعد وزير الداخليه المصري الاسبق
من القاهره سيد رفيق يعني كما استمعت من
المفترض انه التنظيم انه النظام في مصر
اليوم هو في حرب ومواجهه مع تنظيم الدوله
لكن كما يبدو وكما يشير السيد حاتم عزان
انه يكرس جهوده في مواجهه خصومه السياسيين
الداخليين اكثر
لماذا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
طبعا اولا انا اعزي اهل الضحايا في هذا
العمل الارهابي الخفيف وباكد
لحضرتك ان اي عنصر المفاج او المباغته
دائما بيحقق خسائر تبحه خاصه اذا كان تيتم
مع مجموعات تقوم بعمال روتينيه عاديه
ا فانا يعني ما بكلمش على النظام النظام
السياسي انا بتكلم عن اعمال امنيه
احترافيه فلابد من تطوير الحصول بخبر اكبر
على المعلومات الاستخباراتيه اللي تحقق
لنا الاستباق الامنيه ام يعني القوات اللي
كانت ماشيه الموجوده دي او كانت ما ما
خوات مدربه على مواجهه الارهاب او خلافه
ودي خوات ا من المباحث بتقوم باعمال
روتينيه ل المرورات او للتحريات او لخلافه
في في منطقه حلوان وفي منطقه على سوم
مدينه القاهره وحصل اعتداء عليها هم مش
مضربين انهم يواجهوا انما لو كان في دوريه
من القوات الخاصه بتاع الشرطه كان ممكن
يحصل تصدي لهذه المجموعه وما كانش يحصل
الخسائر اللي ح لكن السؤال هنا لماذا يعني
السؤال عن العمل الاستخباراتي المسبق وعن
اي تجميع المعلومات المسبق الذي يفترض ان
يكون جزءا اساسيا من عمل وزاره الداخليه
في هذا المجال اذا كانت تعتبر نفسها في
حرب ومواجهه حقيقيه مع تنظيم الدوله وهذا
ما لا تبدو يعني نتائجه على الارض بشكل
واضح ا ما فيش شك ان العمل الاستخباراتي
ده والمعلومه الاستخباراتيه بتحقق لل
السباقه الامنيه اللي هي بطاق القوات
بتاعه الشرطه او بطاق المواطنين من اي
ضربات فجائيه او اي ضربات مفاجاه ي ما انا
بقول لحضرتك ان عصر المفاجاه وال المباغته
دايما بيحقق خسائر فادحه فلابد من
تطوير المعلومات الاستخباراتيه حتى يمكن
الوصول الى المعلومه اللي هي تحقق لي الا
السباقه الامنيه لتقينا من الضربات اللي
احنا شفناها وحصلت مع القوات الش قوات
الشرطه ا طيب اعود الى ضيفي من القاهره
ايضا محمود ابراهيم سيد محمود يعني عندما
تقول لانه ال التنظيم في هذا المجال تم
تحجيمه نتيجه ماذا تم تحجيم هذا التنظيم
وهو
الذي ب بدا يبادر ويبغض بهذه
الطريقه مره ثانيه طبيعه الارهاب هي الغدر
هي المباغته هي الهجوم المفاجئ ا انت لا
تستطيع في اي دوله في العالم وانا لا اريد
ان ادخل في مقارنات بروكسل فرنسا غيره
وغيره الارهاب بطبيعته غادره نحن لا نتحدث
عن مواجهات مباشره ومفتوحه نستطيع ان ان
نتحدث فيها عن قوه اطراف امام اطراف
يستطيع فرض واحد ان يتسلل معه
بعض الاشياء مثل قنبله او مدفع او الى ذلك
وان
يحدث عدد من القتلى ثم نتحدث عن بيان بعد
ذلك يتبنى هذا العمل تفسر تكرار عفوا كيف
تفسر تكرار هذه الاعمال وبف زمني قصير بين
الواحده والاخرى على ما يدول ذلا اسمحلي
بقى اسمحلي هنا انه لما نراجع الوضع
الامني الان مقارنه بثلاث سنوات ماضيه منذ
مثلا الاعمال الارهابيه التي تمت في اغسطس
2013 حتى الان نحن نتحدث عن منحنى بكل
تاكيد هو منحنى في تنازل باستثناء بعض
المحاولات في سيناء لها وضع خاصه ولكن
فيما يخص الدلتا والقاهره والاسكندريه
وباقي محافظات الجمهوريه نحن بكل اكيد
نتحدث
عن عمليات في العدد اقل في النوعيه اقل في
التاثير اقل هذه مساله يعني ليس بها اي
نقاش ولكن خلط الاوراق هو هو هنا بقى هنا
خلط الاوراق انه البيان الصحفي ل الجماعه
الارهابيه بيقول انه بسبب بعض المعتقلات و
ما الى ذلك هذه المحاوله في خ هذ النقطه
هذه النقطه ساث ساثر في الجزء الثاني من
تيب
سريع هو لم يكن هناك قبل ثلاث سنوات وقبل
انقلاب العسكري من الثالث من يوليو اي
عمليات بهذا الشكل جوه القاهره يعني الضيف
من القاهره بيقول انه هناك انحصار في
وتراجع في هذه العمليات جوه القاهره وسبنا
من سناء على جنب هي بتزيد فيها الاسباب هو
يعلمها واحن نعلمها انما حقيقه الامر انه
قبل الانقلاب العسكري لم يكن هناك اي من
هذه العمليات جوه القاهره ابدا ده هي هي
بتزداد في وتيرتها جوه القاهره مش بتتراجع
على كل مشاهدينا بعد الفاصل نناقش ما اذا
كان هجوم حلوان وا امثال هذا الهجوم تتويج
لفشل سياسي وامني رغم اعلان القاهره انها
لن تتهاون في الدفاع عن امن البلاد
واستقرارها ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
مشاهد اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش مقتل ثمانيه من رجال
الامن المصري في هجوم بحلوان تبناه تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه اعود الى ضيفي في
الاستديو حاتم عزام عضو مجلس الشعب المصري
السابق سيد حاتم اشرت في الجزء الاول من
هذه الحلقه الى الفشل الامني كما تقول في
مواجهه تنظيم الدوله وفي مواجهه الارهاب
بشكل عام ولكن الا تعتقد هنا ان من
المبالغه الطلب من السلطات الان في في مصر
ان تنجح في هذه المواجهه في حين ان دولا
تقوم بتحالفات كبرى ولم تنجح حتى الان في
هزيمه هذا التنظيم لو بصينا لدول لو احنا
بنقارن على دول فيها انظمه ديمقراطيه
منتخبه لا انا اعتقد انه وتيره ما يحدث في
مصر اعلى بكثير مما يحدث في هذه الدول
وانه الحادثه مثل هذه لا تبرر لهذه الدول
ان تعصف بمنطقه يعني ما شفناش مثلا فرنسا
ا رئيس الفرنسي جا هجم على منطقه في جنوب
فرنسا بالطيارات زي ما بيحصل في سين
النهارده وبيتم التعامل معها بهذه
العشوائيه وقتل لابناء شعبه دون هذا ثاني
حاجه انه هذه الدول لا تحارب الارهاب
بالمزيد من العنف وارهاب الدوله هو حقيقه
الوضع في مصر انه الارهاب ينتج عن ارهاب
الدوله ارهاب الدوله السلطه العسكريه التي
استولت على السلطه في مصر بانقلاب عسكري
في الثالث من يول 2013 ا اتت بذري محاربه
الارهاب حينها لم يكن هناك ارهاب
انها كان هناك بعض العمليات في سيناء التي
زادت جدا الان وزادت حدتها بل انه تم
اخلاء مناطق واسعه جدا من سيناء وتم
مهاجمه سيناء واهل سيناء دون اعتبار ودون
تمييز لمن هو الارهابي ومن لا يعني بتتكلم
على تهجير قصري بنتكلم على تدمير للمنازل
وتدمير للمزارع و دور العباده وهكذا انت
تعتبر كل هذه المنطقه ارهاب وبالتالي باتت
هناك حاضنه اكبر للعنف المسلح الانظمه
العس ريه الفاشيه التي تمارس هذا المستوى
من القمع وتمارس هذا المستوى من ارهاب
السلطه بالضروره ينتج عنه ارهاب مضاد وعنف
مضاد من بعض الافراد الاثنين مؤثم وما
نطالبه لمصر الان ان تكون هناك حياه
ديمقراطيه لا تعرف ارهاب الدوله ولا تعرف
بالتبعيه ارهاب الافراد من يحقق الاستقرار
هو الحكم المدني الديمقراطي في مصر هناك
في مصر الان النظام ي يحتفل ببناء السجن
العاشر هناك 60 ال معتقل سياسي هناك كل
المتظاهرين السلمين وهذه الحادثه ايضا قد
تستغل في المزيد من القمع وبالتالي هذه
حلقه مفرغه لن تؤدي الى اي استقرار سيد
رفيق حبيب ا اذا كما استمعت ما حصل يعني
بانه فشل امني للسلطه في مصر ويعني ايضا
بان الشعار الذي اي قامت على اساسه هذه
السلطه و ومحاربه الارهاب هو شعار فاشل
فضلا عن ان الممارسات تؤدي الى توسيع
دائره الخصوم للنظام في مصر ما
رايك انا مش لا اعتصر في الراي مع الاخ
الزميل اللي موجود مع حضرتك مع سامل
الاحترام له لان في فرنسا لما حصل التعدي
اللي حصل ده ا هولاند اعلن الطوارئ واعلن
اجراءات متشدده جدا وكلنا عارفين
الاجراءات اللي حصل فيها تضييق كبير جدا
على الحريات واي دوله و احنا عارفين حتى
بعد احداث سبتمبر في امريكا عملت اجراءات
شديد جدا جدا وخاصه العرب ام و فانا بقول
ان الارهاب لا دين له في اي مكان وفي
اوروبا بالذات لما بيحصل عمليه ارهابيه
بتبقى في هناك اجراءات متشدده جدا وفيها
تطبيق على الحريات وخلاف وانا من رايي ان
في مصر من هنا الارهاب لما بيحصل بالعكس
نا يعني في ارهاب الارهاب التشره
وا الاستاذ اللي مع حضرتك بيقول ما كانش
في ارهاب في القاهره او خلاف لاده حصل في
المناوات وحصل تعددي على امين شرطه اللي
كانت قدام ش الهاب حتى تعدى ذلك الى ضابط
مرور في مدان لبنان وعلى مجموعه من الضباط
قدام جامعه القاهره كل دي اعمال تمت
واعمال كاسفه جدا بس كانت بتتم بايه بان
يحط قنبله في مكان معين في رجال الشرطه ب
المتواجدين المره دي جماعه ارهابيه مسلحه
اعتدت على مجموعه مش مستعده انها ممكن
تواجهه لكن لو كان في مجموعه مسلحه من
القوات العمليات الخاصه كانت ممكن تصدق
لهمم وانا بقول لحضرتك ده ارهاب خسيس جبان
يعني بيضرب ويجري وده برض في قصور انا
يعني لا في قصور برض في المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه اللي تحقق ل السباقه
الامنيه اللي احنا تمثلنا من مواجهه هذا
ال ط سيد محمود ابراهيم هناك مخاوف من ان
تستغل هذه العمليه في مزيد من الممارسات
لقمع الحريات وايضا لمزيد من
الاعتقالات تحت هذا العنوان ا اسمح لي قبل
ان ان اعلق على هذه النقطه ان اوضح ا
الحقائق فقط كان هناك هتاف يهتف المصريون
حينما خرجوا لمواجهه الارهاب او للتفويض
في الارهاب كان يقول يا يحكمون يا يقتلون
ا الذي افرج عن الجهاديين والذي قال حينما
يعود مرسي ستتوقف العمليات في سيناء هي
الجماعه الارهابيه معروف ازرع و معروف ما
ما ما تمارسه مصر كانت يحكمون يقتلون هذا
واختار المصريون الا يحكمهم هؤلاء
الارهابيين ومستعدون لدفع الثمن من قتلاهم
سواء من الشرطه او من المواطنين العاديين
هذه المساله المساله فيما يتعلق بالتضييق
على الحريات ا هذا ايضا خلط متعمد يون به
البعض ا هناك مشاكل الان تواجه المصريين
فيما يخص
مثلا الحاله العامه فيما يخص مثلا نقابه
الصحفيين و وكل هذه الامور هذه الامور
مفهومه ولكن يعني هذه تتم في كل الدول
الديمقراطيه وفي كل المناخات الديمقراطيه
اما الحديث عن ان
هذه الحوادث الارهابيه نحن لا
نعلم شخص او جماعه تم اعتقالها الا وكان
له علاقه بشكل او باخر بتنظيمات ارهابيه
ثم يدعون بعد ذلك انه من اجل فتيات
المحتجزات او ما الى ذلك الجماعه
الارهابيه معروفه يتم مواجهتها امنيا
الخلافات السياسيه
وال المتعلقه بالحريات لا يتدخل فيها
الارهاب و المساله المساله هناك فصل هناك
فصل ما بين حريه التعبير والمشاكل
السياسيه ما بين الخصوم السياسيين وما
يقوم به تنظيم الدوله ما رايك هنا سيد حسم
مختلف تماما طبعا هو الواقع الحال هو انه
كان في كمم اعدام امبارح على مدير قسم
الاخبار في قناه الجزيره وصحفيين اخرين 18
صحفي في السجن ا الزميل من الضيف حضرتك من
القاهره بيقول انه الممارسات الديمقراطيه
يعني زي كل الدول لا مش زي كل الدول ما
حدش بيقتح نقابه صحفيين بهذا الشكل ما حدش
بيعتقل 60 ال واحد بهذا الشكل ماحدش
وبعدين كل المعتقلين ماهش من الاخوان
المسلمين هذه فريا اصبحت عاريه عن الصحه
ومكشوف يعني احنا بنتكلم من كل الطيارات
السياسيه الان فانا عايز اقول انه هذه
السلطه سلطه عسكريه لا تستخدم غير الحلول
العسكريه والحلول الامنيه بمناسبه التفويض
الذي ذكره ضيفك لمحاربه الارهاب اول ما
استخدم هذا التفيد استخدم في اكبر مذبحه
تمت في التاريخ الحديث وهي فض اعتصام
رابعه العدويه والنهضه اللي راح فيه اكثر
من 1ف شهيد بدم بارد من القوات الامنيه
ودي كانت نقطه انطلاق مرحله جديده في مصر
تمارس فيه السلطه هذا القتل خارج نطاق
القانون نحن نقول ان كل القتل خارج نطاق
القانون هو قتل هو عمل ارهابي مؤثم ومجرم
من بدا هذا هذه السلطه العسكريه ومن يستمر
في هذا القمع هو هذه السلطه العسكريه ولن
تفلح هكذا مقاربات في لا حل الارهاب ولا
حل معيشه الناس الحل هو عوده المدنيه
الحياه المدنيه الديمقراطيه اشكرك جزيلا
حاتم عزام واشكر من القاهره محمود ابراهيم
كان معنا عبر سكايب والاستاذ رفيق حبيب
ايضا عبر الهاتف من القاهره شكرا للمتابعه
مشاهدينا والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء